but the part i want to go with today is
so you say cancer culture still on the
right would you i think you would agree
that mainstream media outside of fox is
pretty much on the left i don't think
you would debate that no actually i
would debate okay so
tell me why yeah um so uh i can give you
a thousand examples but first of all
structure wise um
if you say cnn etc and msnbc are
socially liberal i'd say i generally
agree with you okay if you say they're
economically liberal i'd laugh and laugh
and laugh no they're economically
conservative and massively conservative
so cnn for example non-stop can i curse
on here of course
non-stop shits all over medicare for all
every time they talk about it oh
medicare for all costs 34 trillion
dollars hey liar 32 trillion hey liars
why don't you actually also say that
same study first of all paid for by coke
industries
said that it saves 34 trillion so
overall it saves 2 trillion dollars why
do you leave out that context they leave
out that context every time anytime you
talk about a progressive economic
position and you go back to the debates
and see the smug anderson coopers jake
tappers looking down there knows that
bernie sanders going how are you going
to pay for that when we start massive
wars they never ask how you're going to
pay for that when we do massive tax cuts
for the rich they never ask how are you
going to pay for that no they're
definitely economically conservative and
what explains the dichotomy then why are
they socially liberal but economically
conservative because they're corporate
media so what do corporations want why
are they socially liberal because they
want to sell to everyone so i remember
being at a google presentation once and
coke was doing an ad and it was their
not their u.s ad but their international
ad and i was
shocked by how many muslims they had in
the ad right now i'm grow up muslim so
i'm not against it i'm great that's
wonderful it's inclusive etc right but i
was just like wow like a third of this
ad is muslims right then i was like
hello a third of the world is muslims
roughly right and so are they going to
be anti-muslim of course internationally
internationally of course not they got
to sell to 1.6 billion muslims are they
going to be against black people of
course not they got to sell to black
people gay people same thing right so
that's why corporate america and
multinational corporations are socially
liberal but economically they're
viciously conservative they because they
are structured to maximize profit i get
that part and you're right which by the
way that to me
uh uh that to me
eventually
um ends up making them honest if
anything it forces them to be honest and
i know you may disagree with that but at
the same time i think it's fair to say
that anybody
to the right of you is considered
conservative like you you're probably
more on the bernie sanders camp you've
supported it so as a socialist
even a democrat is a conservative to you
even a center left a joe manchin is
conservative to you even a christian
cinema is conservative to you even even
an obama is probably conservative to you
probably a bite is conservative to you
probably hillary clinton is conservative
to you so then if i were to ask you who
would you say
is a liberal in your eyes to the outside
of bernie sanders who would you say
these are some of the liberals today so
let's clarify a couple things so first
of all uh it's much to the
annoyance of my audience i am not a
socialist i'm a capitalist so i'm what i
call a democratic capitalist which i can
explain right please and so
and and to be fair it's not the whole
audience at all the audience generally
likes what i'm saying obviously right
they're our audience right uh but there
is some portion of the left that the
word capitalist uh really uh grinds
their gears yeah i was almost going to
say crystal gear so i was like
anyway um they they don't they don't
like that but i can explain why i i
believe that but in terms of the your
core question of are those people
conservative they're not just
conservative to me manchester cinema
obviously giant conservatives but
honestly biden is a huge conservative
and i can but it's not just to me and by
the way i can show it to you i can show
it to you that's why your policies and
in the polling but it's not just to me
guys i can show you in the polling that
two-thirds of the country is progressive
and if the if if they got beyond the
filter of both right-wing media and
mainstream media corporate media overall
they would think biden is way too
right-wing okay and so and and i
actually can't believe that anybody
would think he's a liberal i can't
believe it he's and so who's uh actually
progressive and and progressive and
liberal are different now a lot of the
left views the word liberal as a little
bit derisive like it's neoliberal like
the word liberal is almost too
conservative so many times yeah but the
word liberal like the word socialism is
almost meaningless because everybody
thinks it's something else when they're
talking about it same with conservative
too yeah well
you tell me because i i you know for me
conservative is is pretty clear but
maybe i'm wrong about that and i'm sure
there's gradations right so but
progressive is the left right so
uh sure aoc bernie sanders uh i i uh
co-founded just democrats so
all the squad jamal bowman corey bush i
love those are progressive those are
your guys those are the people you
support yeah okay so so go back and when
you said
you know you believe the cnns the
msnbc's they're more right-wing socially
liberal but you know fiscally
conservative fine at the same time some
may say
uh jank
you know even though you're taking that
position
if you want to see a channel bashing a
musk you'll see them doing it if you
want to see a channel bashing capitalism
and you know what the wealth you're
doing you'll see them doing it if you'll
never if you want to see a channel
bashing a trump or a desantis or any uh
candidate on the right you'll see on cnn
and msnbc that's true so though somebody
may say well that's where they are the
every candidate that i put up say the
right is saying this every candidate i
put up desantis trump you know nikki
haley they keep passions right so
someone may say they're far left you're
saying they don't do that no so you
think you think cnn msnbc a mainstream
media supports trump in the city no not
at all okay so let me explain because
you mentioned a couple of different
people there and that's why i wanted to
clarify sure so are they against trump
of course that's uh that's super obvious
are they against the santas yes they are
okay because they view who are they for
they're for the establishment they're
for the status quo when you're a
multi-billion dollar corporation you
know why you like the status quo because
you're at the top you don't want to
change anything when you're at the time
okay but when you say nikki haley you're
actually wrong nikki haley cross over to
establishment and they love the
establishment so for example chris
christie establishment republican
abc cnn all giving multi-million dollar
documentary advertising all around chris
christie wait why is abc and cnn doing
these giant specials on chris christie
out of nowhere he hasn't done anything
in years and years and years because
they love establishment republicans all
my life i've watched meet the press
blow john mccain and every republican
that's ever kind of oh the beloved john
mccain which war would you like to start
now senator that's such a great idea
let's start another one tax cuts for the
rich why that's brilliant let's have
another guest on he agrees this is a
democrat you know and you fill in the
blank
claire mccaskill joe mansion it doesn't
matter look at that they also agree with
tax cuts for the rich well i guess
everybody we all agreed tax cuts for the
rich so they don't like trump because
he's a he's a populist i think that he's
a fake populist but at least he's
playing that route and he's wild he's
out of control and he leads to
instability so the establishment does
not like that if you enjoyed this short
clip click over here to watch another
short clip and if you want to watch the
entire episode the entire podcast click
here
[Music]